buso ragazzi e benvenuti a tutti o
abbozzare una sega che i video escono al
pomeriggio cielo da rari ragazzi su un
po guys perché oggi effettivamente
volevo provare quello che non ho
trattato 8 che lo slide amico io voglio
capire se c'è questa modalità so che è
una figata perché immagino però
effettivamente non l'ho ancora vista e
sono curiosissimo di vedere che tanti
lato fuori visto che a me piace il
basket sono anche da dove della nota a
new orleans di horror stavi game ma che
cosa ne frega poi in realtà e kaspar lo
fa è un mini gioco sostanzialmente che
immagino ci sia anche nel main event
quello normale di paul goude però è
talmente fatto bene che ci hanno
dedicato alla mappa ha detto letta
facciamolo perché troppo figo e hanno
fatto bene a giudicare la commissione
della mappa non capita la palla latini
in mano a ok è mala non si capisce una
sega
la prendo io non l'ho presa ma ragazzi
la domanda è una e una volta che questo
è sbagliato ma non è giusto che la
domanda è una mala fa le palle sparlano
nel mezzo ok si quindi e tipo quel gioco
e tipo il gioco del quanti pochi frame
fanno ste palle gol
solo con la pa nella vaschetta
attenzione estere che proprio lui sono
bravo lo fa vincendo 6 a 4 attenzione ma
è stata avversario che però non crolla
porca vacca
ma tanto ragazzi è veramente difficile
togliergli rai non gliela poi toglierlo
che basta gravarlo la torta sono un
fenomeno che difesa che difesa non lo
sapeva laga scusatemi se non con la fare
pratica tensione incredibile ma stiamo
lottando per il prestito pallone vinto
lui a locazioni passive passati quadro
sto io
meno male che è caduta non di passare
per forza giusta pedana qua perché
andare direttamente nel coso è infatti
sta palleria è a rischio
nola
non cercano di fare una difesa pazze non
vedo neanche dove eccola lo vediamo
neanche dov'eravamo perfetto sono
scappate ce l'ho fatta siamo a 19 sta
stravincendo ho fatto una difesa la
paura e se vogliamo metterla proprio
ovviamente i buchi su lei guarda il favi
come corre mamma mia
proprio lui 23 punti raga stati
bravissimi
cioè niente da dire agli altri superiori
superiori sono certo sulla palla per
togliere
bene come partenza non è male
effettivamente se sia solo store
minigioco me la cavo potrebbero fare sta
cosa anche per quello del calcio per pol
bol cacchio che a me piace tantissimo ma
qui non è una volta suonava eliminazioni
e l'ultimo cosa fai uno contro uno scusa
come fai lezione prossimi giorni slam
dunk non avrei mai detto o non mi disse
ragazzi fateci caso nessuno chasta
gallina c'ero solo io
va bene a me noale tra l'altro almeno mi
sembra più particolare ed che la prendo
a partenza è buona per me solo per me
perché gli altri non solo che stanno
facendo
ragazzi ma gli altri che cacchio state
facendo scusa qualcuno si sta difendendo
il paese
l'ho tolto ottenuto ottenuto ottenuto
sta sbattendo lo tengo lo tengono presso
perfetto in difesa ragazzi sono un
fenomeno e non so cosa cacchio ciò non
posso fermare tutti però è certa temi la
mano e che soprattutto io anche qua c'è
gioco da un minuto e sto cercando di
fare tutto io quindi attenzione è stata
la palla tiro testate le palle per
allontanarle mi sembra che tirava
testate la cosa più utile da fare perché
va molto più veloce a quel punto per
questo caso vedi che volevo scrollarmi
notizia faccio prima a fare così almeno
non prendono niente frate fratesi qua
quando io ho aspettato la difesa non c'è
riuscito ai va buttata sono bravissimo
la gabibbi amica e bellissima vabbè
fermi i tassi sono di paul gay se la
migliore mai fatta change my mind no al
si stia dicendo di un punto abbia vinto
pazzesco e meno male che ho fatto quel
canestro
meno male abbia vinto di un punto solo
vabbè andiamo setter maine
come facciamo adesso all montella
cosa centra a perché per fare per fare
una finale degna devono fare per forza
formazione che io pensavo facesse
roseland anche fino alla fine tipo
adesso 3 contro 3 poi uno contro 215 non
si poteva fare col mode prof
tra tutte propofol monte anche quella mi
fa piu schifo da sempre
vabbè proviamo ragazzi vi prometto nulla
la voglia staffa mamma mia cosa olio
detto orco demonio magari la manca
magari a manca figura peccato che fa il
monte ne abbiano rovinato esperienza
però per il resto una figata ragazzi
l'ultima l'ultima effettivamente buona
possibilità che abbiamo
ok la partenza questa volta stato e
basta perché se no vado solo in difesa
devo farmi nikolic attacca che se no ok
11 sembra che siamo molti di più noi in
attacco che mi sbaglio la palla d'oro
dice la cia abbiamo letteratura perdevi
fermo gli avversari anzi bellissimo
ottimo sprint one del panico la palla
d'oro ma no no cosa f certo certo
i chip iac come dov'è finito il pallone
d'oro dove do cosa è successo
cosa è successo nel mondo spiega miceli
veramente non ho parole
quindi lo saprà verità dove qua è finito
parla ma come cacchio è possibile no di
qua siamo in due che abbiamo st palla
perché niente l'hanno spinta troppo
avanti per prenderlo o forse no mica
entravano e culo l'ho spinta l'ho tolta
dalle balle ragazzi sono tutti qua io
sto di sto tenendo due palle d'oro sto
tenendo poté qualcuno fa qualcosa della
mia casa city squadra cioè vi prego sono
due palle d'oro qui si entra non abbiamo
perso io tolgo questa poi togliete
l'altra voi avete tolto l'altra diamo
uno è finita vetro color lava e finita
mentre quando stava entrando nel
canestro con la palla che culo se fosse
durata un secondo in più a valida
avremmo perso avranno rosicato parecchio
per sarò però allora io esco andare
subito sul pallone di qua per te ecco
buttato avanti la gara siamo due palloni
avanti vai tu con loro porti questo lo
porti to aspetto un canestro per
buttarli
eccolo qua ma la d'oro buttata lì la
palla normale ottenuta ad ora anche
quinta stato sulla palla d'oro perfetto
dove cosa cacchio è successo è il
canestro che volevo fare 360 pensi come
era una palla d'oro detto non mi sembra
il caso
ho perso tempo non si è fatta dov'è la
palla e spariva che culo che c'hanno ma
può mai essere arrotolata dentro che con
1 finale
ok ok ai vice pd quindi tipi di film di
philippe in dipinti questi che mi
tengono vai vai ride ma ho la mia ero da
ero dritto cosa mi tocchi perfetto
ragazzi stanno facendo tutti i punti
gialli ma che calcio e stanno facendo i
miei compagni di dietro ok ma perché che
cantiere
prendila con questa fanno festa finita
dai 10 stanno facendo sono punti
avversari perché i ragazzi cosa fate
facendo di lei ho avuto culo anche io
meno male a me passata sopra questi si
tengono per mano abbiamo perso abbiamo
piano interno da 5000 5
niente l'ho strangolata 5 peccato ho
dato il massimo non è bastato questo era
fogari su slam dunk molto molto figo
però mi sia piaciuto paris a pensare
tanto vedi volgari devo provare questa
modalità perché mi attirava troppo
contratta curiosità e noi come sempre ci
vediamo al prossimo video dei ragazzi
[Musica]